WILFRED MCCLAY: An
incalculable advantage
that the Americans had I
can express in two words--
George Washington.
Declaring independence
was the easy part.
Defeating the mightiest
military power in the world,
that was another matter.
The United States,
such as they were--
the disunited United States--
went into this conflict
with huge and fairly obvious
disadvantages.
But all was not lost because
the Americans did enjoy
certain very real advantages.
For one thing, they had
only to play defense.
They needed not to
win every battle.
They needed not
to win any battles
so long as they were able
to keep the war going long
enough to exhaust the patience
and willingness to fight
of the British opponent.
Another advantage, an
incalculable advantage,
that the Americans had I
can express in two words--
George Washington.
They had the person of George
Washington, a man of such fine
and admired--
widely, universally admired
character, and military skills,
political savvy.
He commanded the loyalty
of nearly all Americans,
and thus served as a
unifying force when
he was made commander in chief
of the Revolutionary American
forces.
He signaled his willingness
to play this role
by appearing at the
Second Continental
Congress in Philadelphia
wearing his military uniform.
So he ready to play,
and from June 1775 on
was commander in chief
of the Continental Army.
He received the position and
accepted it on the condition
that he received no pay for it.
That was the kind of guy
George Washington was.
He was charismatic,
courageous, selfless, tireless.
He was not a world-class
intellect like Jefferson.
But he was always
learning and had
a great deal of practical
and prudential wisdom.
The greatest challenge
that Washington would face
was simply one of recruiting
and holding together
a credible army.
This was not an easy job.
There was a sense of fragility
about the whole enterprise
so that the morale
and willingness
to serve of soldiers
waxed and waned depending
on circumstances in the
field and weather conditions,
which were very important
in the American Revolution.
In August of 1776, not
long after the Declaration,
he had 28,000 men
under his command.
By December, that number
had shrunk to 3,000.
What had happened was
that those troops have
been driven from New York
City by British regulars,
back and back and back until
they ended up in Pennsylvania.
The army's morale was bad.
It was always unstable.
It was always hostage to events,
to successive peaks and valleys
and consequent hope and
despair, depending on how
the war effort was going.
Washington through all of
this had to keep a cool head.
He had to not be to
influenced either
by the giddiness of success
or the despondency of failure.
As it turned out that
winter, 1776 to '77,
was an exceptionally bad winter.
And it made for a gloomy
time of discouragement.
Fortunately for
the patriot cause,
Tom Paine chose that time to
write yet another contribution
to the war effort, a
series of pamphlets
called The American Crisis.
Which the most famous lines
from that, which some of you
may have heard, go like
this at the beginning.
He says, "These are the
times that try men's souls.
The summer soldier and
the sunshine patriot
will, in this crisis,
shrink from the service
of his country; but
he that stands it
now deserves the love and
thanks of man and woman."
Yes, he conceded that
things look very bad.
But the harder of the conflict,
the more glorious the triumph.
Paine put it just the
way Washington would have
liked to have been able to.
And George Washington
ordered that Paine's words
from The American Crisis
be read to his troops who
were suffering through
this bitter winter.
And they had the desired
effect of rousing them
to a new burst of
fighting spirit.
And then on Christmas night of
1776, Washington struck back.
He led a force through
snow and sleet,
across the Delaware River.
We've all seen the
painting of that,
which is not exactly
historically accurate, but who
cares?
It's a beautiful painting.
And he surprised at
dawn a sleeping force
of Hessians, the hated Hessians,
at Trenton in New Jersey.
A week later, his forces had a
similar triumph at Princeton.
Two small victories
brought reason for hope
that they could be auguries
of good things to come.
It appeared the American forces
would not be defeated quickly,
as the British had hoped.
SPEAKER: Thank you for watching.
We hope you're enjoying
our highlights series,
and invite you to explore
all of Hillsdale College's
online courses.
They are free and for
everyone who loves to learn.